[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا وسهلا بكم في هذه
المقابله الخاصه مع السيد حسين الشيخ امين
سر اللجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه وعضو مركزيه فتح نساله عن قمه
العقبه ونتائجها والكثير من ايضا القضايا
الفلسطينيه المختلفه اهلا وسهلا ابو جهاد
اهلا وسهلا بعد اسبوع من انتهاء لقاء
العقبه
هل بدات اسرائيل تتراجع عن بعض الخطوات
احاديه الجانب التي طرحتموها هناك وهل
هناك ما يؤسس لاستئناف حقيقي للمفاوضات مع
الجانب الاسرائيلي يعني اولا اسرائيل جاءت
الى مؤتمر العقبه مكرهه ومجبره
هذه حكومه يمينيه متطرفه
برنامجها قائم على الترانسفير والضم
وفي ظل التصعيد الاسرائيلي الاخير كان في
هناك حراك اقليمي ودولي لعقد مثل هذا
اللقاء
لتصويب المسار بالحد الادنى
بيننا وبين
الاسرائيليين
وبناء عليه التصريحات التي صدرت من
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي وبعض المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين في عقاب مؤتمر العقبه تدلل
على ان هذه الحكومه ما زالت ملتزمه
ببرنامجها وليس بشيء اخر احنا ما عشناش
الوهم
ولا نعيش الوهم حتى هذه اللحظه
امكانيه
الافق السياسي مع هذه الحكومه غير وارد
ولكن في السياسه لا يوجد فراغ
الفراغ في حال حدوثه يملا غيرك المقعد
الشاغر يملا غيرك في ظل يعني
هذه النتائج هل ايضا ستذهبون الى قمه شرم
الشيخ هذا مرهون الان في هناك تنسيق بيننا
وبين الاشقاء في الاردن وفي مصر حول هذا
الموضوع هناك التزامات قطعتها اسرائيل على
نفسها في مؤتمر العقبه الان المطلوب ان
يكون في هناك استعداد للالتزام والتمثيل
وتحديدا وقف الاجراءات الاحاديه من جانب
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بدعم بالاستيطان
مرورا بالاقتحامات والقتل والاسترتسكو
بالحرم الشريف هدم البيوت كل هذه القضايا
التي كانت مطروحه على الطاوله في قمه
العقبه اذا في هناك ضمانات
من جانب الحكومه الاسرائيليه تعطى للاطراف
المعنيه في مؤتمر شرم الشيخ نحن لن نتردد
اطلاقا في الذهب لا شك انه اجتماع العقبه
حدث بعد سلسله زيارات امريكيه مهمه لرمال
الله
هل ضغط عليكم من الجانب الامريكي
لحضور هذا اللقاء وكيف تصف طبيعه علاقتكم
حاليا مع الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه بعد
قطيعه طويله مع اداره ترامب مع انه انتم
تقولون ايضا ان الامريكان لم يقدموا شيئا
حتى الان مجرد وعود احنا اطلاقا لما تردد
في الذهاب الى العقبه احنا اي منتدى اي
ساحه اي هيئه اي منصه احنا مستعدين ان
نذهب اليها احنا اصحاب الروايه الحقيقيه
التي يجب ان تكون
حاضره على اي طاوله في ظل غياب
الروايه الحقيقيه عن الحضور المكان سيكون
للروايه الزائفه فلذلك لا نتردد اطلاقا في
الحضور ولم يضغط علينا بالحضور وتم العبق
العقبه كان بالتنسيق بيننا وبين اشقائنا
في الاردن والاشقاء المصريين وايضا مع
الاداره الامريكيه والاداره الامريكيه
وافقت على الحضور كطرف مباشر في مؤتمر
العقبه وانا برايي بانه هذا الحضور هو
لصالح الفلسطيني انا صاحب الروايه
الحقيقيه لا اخشى ولا اهم من مواجهات
اسرائيل
فلذلك اطلاقا لم نتعرض للضغوط في هذا
الموضوع العلاقه مع الاداره الامريكيه الى
الاسف الشديد بانه حتى هذه اللحظه لم تقدم
الاداره الامريكيه اي مبادره من جانبها
لتحريك العمليه السياسيه وتحريك الافق
السياسي المشكله مع اسرائيل ليست مشكله
امنيه ولا ترتيبات امنيه عمق المشكله
وجوهر المشكله مع اسرائيل هي سياسيه
اسرائيل دوله محتله لذلك المطلوبه ان يكون
في هناك تغليب للمصاري السياسي والترتيبات
الامنيه تاتي تحصيل حاصل بعد ان نصل الى
صيغ سياسيه متفق عليها وفي ظل التزام
اسرائيلي فيها لذلك شددنا في العقبه نحن
على شرعيه الدوليه الاتفاقيات الموقعه
بيننا وبين الحكومه الاسرائيليه وقف
الاجراءات الاحاديه ولم نتحدث في اي
ترتيبات امنيه بالمناسبه
الانتقال الان الى المربع الاخر واجبار
اسرائيل ان تاتي اليه هو الهدف
الاستراتيجي كما قلت مره ثانيه المشكله
ليست امنيه مع اسرائيل المشكله مشكله
احتلال اسرائيلي للارض الفلسطينيه هناك من
يعني ينتقد وينتقد ذهابكم الى مؤتمر
العقبه بسبب وجود ما حدث في مدينه نابلس
وهذا العدد الكبير من الضحايا الفلسطينيين
الناس مش قادره تفهم يعني كيف نذهب ونجلس
معهم في ظل اراقه الدماء الكبيره التي
تحدث في الساحه الفلسطينيه كيف بتبرروا
هذا الموضوع للكثير من المنتقدين حق الناس
وانا برايي بانه حتى المعارضه محقه
في رفضه للذهاب الى العقبه وانا احترم
الراي المعارض في هذا
الموضوع واحترم الراي العام لانه احنا
ذهبنا في توقيت صعب جدا الدم الفلسطيني
كان يراق في شوارع مدننا وكورونا
ومخيماتنا ولكن كمان قلت انا في السياسه
لا يوجد فراغ احنا
يجب ان
نحسن في ادائنا في توظيف كفاح ونضال شعبنا
الفلسطيني وتضحياته يجب ان توظفه في خدمه
القضيه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ويجب ان توظفوا
سياسيا هذا الدم الفلسطيني مش مشاعر فلذلك
يجب ان يوظف في كل
المنصات وفي كل المحطات وفي كل الهيئات
وفي كل المنتديات الدوليه لا يجوز
المقاطعه في السياسه تعني الفراغ والفراغ
يعني وجود البديل لذلك انا اتفهم تماما
موقف الراي العام واتفهم موقف المعارضه
الفلسطينيه في هذا الموضوع بالعكس انا
احيي المعارضه الفلسطينيه ولكن علينا ان
ندرك تماما اين وكيف ومتى نعبر عن راينا
هذا في غايه الاهميه حتى يكون هناك موقف
فلسطيني سواء كما معارضه او موالاه في
النهايه يجب ان توظف كل المواقف في خدمه
قضيتك
ساسالك بعد الفاصل ابو جهاد عن موضوع
الاستراتيجيه الفلسطينيه وان كان لدى
الفلسطينيين استراتيجيه واضحه في اداره
الصراع مع الجانب الاسرائيلي مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا بعد هذا الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام نعود لاستكمال هذه
المقابله مع السيد حسين الشيخ ابو جهاد
البعض يقول ان الفلسطينيين يفتقدون
الاستراتيجيه واضحه في التعامل مع اسرائيل
ويقولون اننا نتعامل بان الفلسطينيين
يتعاملون مع الجانب الاسرائيلي مع اداره
الصراع بردود فعل اذا ما تغيرت الاداره
الامريكيه اذا ما تغيرت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اذا اي يعني اجراء اسرائيل
يحاد الجانب نقوم برد الفعل عليه ولا يوجد
لدينا استراتيجيه واضحه لا يجدد
الفلسطينيين الاستراتيجيه واضح ما رايك هل
لديكم استراتيجيه واضحه ما هي اهدافكم
حاليا اهداف قياده الفلسطينيه حاليا وما
هي الاستراتيجيه اطلاقا هذا الغلام بغير
دقيق
الاستراتيجيه الفلسطينيه واضحه في في
سلوكه في اداءه وفي مواجهته لاسرائيل
وللاحتلال الاسرائيلي هذا عدو شمس ومتوحش
وهذه الحكومه برنامجها واضح تماما
ترانسفير والتهجير والضم عليك ان تدرك
تماما وان تصنع جمله من التكتيكات التي
تصب في خدمه استراتيجيتك في المحصل
النهائيه رحيل الاحتلال هاي
المهم المركزيه والاستراتيجيه الان هي
تثبيت الشعب الفلسطيني على ارضه امام هذه
السياسه المجرمه الاسرائيليه نحن لا نمتلق
لا دبابات ولا طائرات ولكن نمتلك قرار
واراده شعب يريد ان يبقى على هذه الارض
وان يعيش على هذه الارض وان يواجه هذا
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وان يواجه سياسات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ويجب ان نوظف كل ما
لدينا من امكانيات على الصعيد المحلي
والاقليمي والدولي لخدمه هذا الموضوع وهذا
الهدف هذه الاستراتيجيه الفلسطينيه تثبيت
شعبك على هذه الارض امام حكومه تفكر
بالترانسفير التاجير
والضم ضم الاراضي هذا هو مشروع هذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه شو الاستراتيجيه
المركزي ه التي يجب ان تكون عندك في الطرف
الفلسطيني هي تثبيت شعبك في ارض وفي بلده
في وطنه
[موسيقى]
عشناه في فتره الشهيد ابو عمار الله يرحمه
انا برايي بانه الشعب الفلسطيني لدي من
الامكانيات والمقومات الداخليه التي تحصن
جبهه الداخليه اكثر بكثير مما يعتقد البعض
لذلك في هناك مؤسسات وفي اطر هي صاحبه
القرار في المحصله النهائيه وهناك شعب
فلسطيني هو صاحب الاختيار والقرار عبر
صندوق الاقتراع لذلك انا اتمنى ان لا
ننزلق كثيرا في
البروباندا الموجهه وبالذات طيب موجه من
خصومنا ومن اعدائنا للاسف الشديد لذلك انا
واثق تماما الشعب الفلسطيني حي ويستطيع ان
يواجه
اي طارئ او اي فراغ ممكن ان يحصل في اي
لحظه على على على الوضع الفلسطيني اطلاقا
اطلاقا انواتك تماما انه الشعب الفلسطيني
قادر على مواجهه هذه التحديات ولديه ارث
كبير
من
الديمقراطيه في مؤسساته
وقادر ان يذهب الى الخيار الصح البوصله لن
تتوه عند الشعب الفلسطيني في النهايه انا
اقول بكل صراحه اي رئيس فلسطيني قادم يجب
ان ياتي عبر صندوق الاقتراع لا بقرار
اقليمي ولا بقرار دوله ولن ياتي على ظاهر
دبابه اسرائيليه منظمه تحرير الفلسطينيه
بشكل عام تتبنى موضوع المقاومه الشعبيه
السلميه في مواجهه اسرائيل ولكن لدينا
الان انتشار لافت لمسلحين مسلحين حتى من
حركه فتح يعني من صغار الشباب من حركه فتح
سواء في جنين او في نابلس كيف ترون هذا
الموضوع كيف تتعاملون معه وخصوصا ان هناك
ضغوط عليكم ايضا لمحاوله احتواء هذه
الظاهره
ما زلنا ملتزمين بالشرعيه الدوليه ما زلنا
ملتزمين بالمقاومه الشعبيه السلميه في
مواجهه هذا الوحش المحتل
مربع العنف والسيد فيه
مربع العنف الاله العسكريه الاسرائيليه هي
التي تريد ذلك لذلك نحن ما زلنا ملتزمين
في هذا الموضوع كل الحاله الفلسطينيه التي
تراها هي تعبير على ردود فعل على هذا
العنف والاجرام الذي ارتكب بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني يوميا وبالمناسبه اغلب ردود
الفعل الفلسطينيه حتى الان هي ردود فرديه
من الناس لم تعد تحتمل هذا الاجرام
الاسرائيلي ولكن نحن على المستوى الرسمي
ما زلنا ملتزمين تماما بالمقاومه الشعبيه
السلميه
ونرى فيها الطريق الذي يضع الاحتلال في
زاويه الحرج الكبير ولكن لا تستطيع ان
تمنع ردود فعل شعبيه فرديه امام هذا
الاجرام حرق البيوت مثل حواره مجزره نابلس
مجزره جنين والمسلسل مستمر لذلك من يستطيع
ان يمنع اي رده فعل من اي مواطن فلسطيني
على هذه الاعتداد الاعتداءات والجرائم
التي ترتكب من جيش الاحتلال ومن قطعان
المستوطنين ولكن الا تخشون ان تتحول من
رده فعل واعمال فرديه الى عمل جماعي وقت
ايضا تذهب يعني تشارك فيه عناصر من
الاجهزه الامنيه ونذهب الى الى مواجهه
كبيره كما حدث في انتفاضه عام 2000 بشكل
دموي لا تخشون من كبر هذه الظاهره وان
تتعظم بسبب كما قلت انت
الاسرائيليه والعنف الاسرائيلي
مازال واضح تماما في هذا الموضوع
يعني في رؤيتنا للاشتباك الميداني مع
حكومه الاحتلال نحن ارتكز على قاعده
المقاومه الشعبيه السلميه الذي يضعف
السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ويضعف المؤسسه
الامنيه هي اسرائيل
الحصار المالي المفروض على السلطه
الفلسطينيه الاقتحامات الاجتياحات اخذ
المسؤوليه الامنيه كامله في كل الضفه
الغربيه من جانب الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هدفه
الاستراتيجي هو اضعاف هذه السلطه
الفلسطينيه اذا لم ندرك ذلك ولم نعرف كيف
ندير هذا الصراع مع هذا الاحتلال انا
برايي انه ممكن ان نقع في الخطا الكبير
لذلك ما زلنا مصرين محددين برنامجنا
محددين بوصلتنا في هذا الموضوع ولكن في
نفس الوقت انا باكد انه من حق شعبنا
الفلسطيني
ان يرد على هذه الاجزاء من عنده الضمانه
انه اي مواطن فلسطيني لا يرد على حرق بيته
او مزروعاته او قتل قريبه او قتل ابن عمه
الى اخره ربما يعني موضوع اضعاف السلطه
الفلسطينيه ياخذنا الى سؤال انهاء السلطه
الفلسطينيه وهي يعني خطه كانت اسرائيل قد
تحدثت طرف اسرائيل تحدثت فيها وان يكون
هناك وطن الدوله الفلسطينيه تقام في قطاع
غزه وهذا ربما ياخذنا للعلاقه بينكم وبين
حركه حماس موضوع انهاء الانقسام الذي طالب
بشكل كبير موضوع الحوار مع حركه حماس
وموضوع الخشيه من ان فعلا ان هناك من يعمل
لاقامه دوله فلسطينيه فقط في قطاع غزه هل
تبحثون هذا الموضوع كيف ترون اليوم لم يعد
خفي على احد
هناك
اقطاب رئيسيه في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تنادي باسقاط السلطه وانهيار السلطه
والجزء الثاني من الحكومه الاسرائيليه لن
يبكي عليها اذا سقطت وانهارت يعني بالجوهر
كلاهما يريد اسقاط السلطه
الفلسطينيه ونحن ذلك ونعرف ذلك وقلت كل
هذه السياسه المتبعه الان من جانب الحكومه
الاسرائيليه هي تصب في النهايه في هذا
الاتجاه
والمشروع مشروع دوله غزه ومشروع قديم جديد
وما زال هذا المشروع موجود على الطاوله
لذا العديد من الجهات مشروع دوله غزه
وتعبيد الاحتلال في الضفه الغربيه
الان احنا
لوحده الموقف الفلسطيني
ولخلق جبهه وطنيه فلسطينيه عريضه في
مواجهه هذا العدوان الاسرائيلي وهذا
التحدي الكبير مع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
هناك حوار هادئ
يجري بيننا وبين حركه حماس انا اتمنى
ان يجد طريقه بالاتجاه الصحيح هذا الحوار
وان نخرج
بمقاربات
مشتركه بيننا وبين حركه حماس لحمايه
المشروع الوطني الفلسطيني ولحمايه شعبنا
الذي يتعرض يوميا الى
الجرائم الاسرائيليه في حوار
لم يقطع شوطا طويلا هذا الحوار انا اتمنى
في اطار الخطه على اقل تقدير او البرنامج
المقدم من جانبنا احنا مقدمين لحركه حماس
برنامج من ثلاث ابعاد او ثلاث مستويات
في هناك المقاربه السياسيه في المقاربه
النضاليه في انهاء الانقسام والشراكه
هل انتم مطلعون على بعض المفاوضات ربما
مباشره وغير المباشره التي تجريها حركه
حماس مع مع الجانب الاسرائيلي او مع اطراف
اقليميه هل توضعون في صوره هذه المفاوضات
والعلاقات في قطاع غزه ام يعني لماذا
اجاوب عليه في هذا الموضوع انه انا بعرف
المفاوضات اللي بعملها انا مع اسرائيل لان
المفاوضات اللي بعملها انا مع اسرائيل فوق
الطاوله وليس تحت الطاوله
في الاخر اللي محتل بلدنا واللي محتل
شعبنا اسرائيل بدي افوض مين انا بفوضه
علنا ولدي الثقه لانه انا صاحب الحق وانا
صاحب الروايه الصح
ولا افاوض اسرائيل بالباطن اذا البعض
بفاوض اسرائيل بالباطن ما عنديش اطلاله
موسعه على ما يجري في الباطن ولذلك بقدر
اجاوب عن انفسنا اللي بفوت بالباطن بقدر
يجاوب عن حاله تمام بالنسبه لاسرائيل
اسرائيل في في اطار يعني شكل جديد انقسام
ربما انقسام كبير حاليا انقسام ايدولوجي
انقسام ديني داخل اسرائيل هناك تظاهرات في
تل ابيب غير مسبوقه ما هي مصلحه
الفلسطينيين وكيف هل يستفيد الفلسطينيون
من مصلحه الفلسطيني ان يفعلوا حيال ما
يجري داخل اسرائيل في داخل اولا ما يجري
في داخل اسرائيل فيما يتعلق بالجوانب لها
علاقه بطبيعه الدوله الديمقراطيه
والليبراليه الدوله كما يدعون او في
الجوانب القانونيه هي مشكله اسرائيليه
داخليه لا علاقه لنا فيها اطلاقا ما
يعنينا هو برنامج هذه الحكومه اتجاه الشعب
الفلسطيني برنامج هذه الحكومه تجاه الشعب
الفلسطيني هو برنامج
اذا يجب ان نبني سياساتنا على هذا الاساس
والموكب من هذه الحكومه هو مرهوم
ببرنامجها تجاهنا تجاه الشعب الفلسطيني
وبناء عليه احنا بنحدد خطواتنا الداخليه
المحليه الفلسطينيه وكذلك سلوكنا وادائنا
الاقليمي والدولي على هذا الاساس اما
المظاهرات التي خرجت في المدن الاسرائيليه
في الداخل بعد مجزره حواره انا احييها انا
احيي كل من خرج في المدن الاسرائيليه
للتعبير عن الرفض لهذا السلوك الاجرامي
اللي ارتكبوا جيش الاحتلال وقطعان
المستوطنين تجاه المواطنين الفلسطينيين في
حواره من حرب بيوتهم ومحلاتهم وسياراتهم
واستباحه واستباحه هذه البلده بهذه
الطريقه هذا نفس نحن نحييه ونشد على
اياديهم هل ما زالت هل ما زالت تنسيق
الامني متوقف مع اسرائيل وفي اي مستوى
حاليا تجري للاتصالات بين الجانب
الفلسطيني متوقف بالكامل احنا بعد مجزر
الجنين
اتخذت القياده الفلسطينيه قرار واضح وصريح
بوقف التنسيق الامني وهو قرار سياسي وليس
قرار امني بمعنى اننا بدانا نفكر جديا
بالانتقال من اللعب في مربع اسرائيل في
قصه ان العلاقه علاقه امنيه الى المربع
الاخر
العلاقه مع اسرائيل هي علاقه احتلال يحتل
الارض شعب اخر وبناء عليه يجب ان نعيد
توصيف العلاقه
مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه احد هذه القرارات
كان هو وقف التنسيق الامني لم يعد تنسيق
امني اصلا اسرائيل بالاساس لم تعد تعترف
ان هناك جهه ممكن ان تنسق معها اسرائيل هي
التي تستبيح البلد
تستبيح كل مدننا وقرانا ومخيماتنا وبناء
عليه كان بالضروره يجب ان ناخذ هذا القدر
ويجب ان يتم اعاده تصويب العلاقه مع
اسرائيل على انها يجب ان تكون علاقه شعب
تحت الاحتلال مع دوله محتله
ويجب ان نبني سياستنا على هذا الاساس
بمعنى داخليا واقليميا ودوليا
على الصعيد السؤال الاخير يعني على الصعيد
الاقليمي علاقتكم مع الدول العربيه كان
هناك تصريحات السعوديه واضحه يوم امس
بخصوص ما قاله حول محو دوله محو قريه
حواره والعديد من الاجراءات هل انتم على
تواصل يومي او اسبوعي او شهري مع الاطراف
العربيه بخصوص التعامل مع هذه الحكومه
التي تصفونها بالاكثر تطرفا احنا على
تنسيق عالي جدا مع اشقاء العرب كل الاشقاء
العرب دون استثناء
وبالعكس المواقف العربيه
الواضحه والجليه في هذا الموضوع تعبر عن
مستوى التنسيق القائم بيننا وبين اشقائنا
العرب في كل المحافل في كل المحافل
الاقليميه والدوليه منسق على مدار الساعه
والموقف العربي وموقف
مؤازر ومساند ومتضامن بالكامل مع الشعب
الفلسطيني في كفاحه ونضاله ضد هذه
العصابات التي تستبيح ارضنا ودمنه لذلك
انا اثمن هذه العلاقه مع اشقائنا العرب
وانا واثق تماما انها ستبقى في هذه
الدائره ولن تخرج منها شكرا شكرا اذا
اعزائي المشاهدين الى هنا ناتي لنهايه هذا
اللقاء الخاص مع السيد حسين الشيخ امين سر
اللجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه تحرير الفلسطينيه
كونوا معنا في اللقاءات اخرى شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]